all right we begin with a fox news alert
fedex workers delivering the first
shipment of pfizer's covet 19
vaccine that's right this is a brand new
video just into us it's one of many
shipments being delivered across the
country
on this monday this means we get to get
back to normalcy
eventually ashley stromer is live at st
barnabas hospital that's up in the bronx
where doctors are waiting for their
delivery when you see these shots
saving lives actually this is incredible
it really is ainsley and those vaccines
could get underway
as soon as this morning as you said here
at st barnabas in the bronx says
they are expected to get their first
batch of doses anytime
now fedex shared this video saying it
safely made the first deliveries this
morning
that shipment confirmed to be on the
east coast
the historic vaccine approval last week
coming five years earlier than most
vaccines
dr jerome adams joined us moments ago to
discuss how it happened take a listen
there were no cutting of scientific
corners it was the cutting of
administrative red tape it was massive
funding which allowed us to scale up
production
and there was no cutting of scientific
corners just cutting of red tape
as you just heard him say and then the
first pfizer biontech vaccines
were distributed from michigan people
could be seen cheering on the trucks
leaving some people holding
trump signs too dr mancep slowly
claiming concerns about a shortage in
doses
saying another vaccine could be approved
soon
our plan from day one has been to have a
portfolio of products
pfizer is one of them moderna which
likely will be approved by the by friday
probably this coming week
is able to produce 100 million doses in
the first quarter
hhs secretary alex azar says the u.s is
on track to give 100 million doses by
march
we could have every nursing home patient
vaccinated in the united states by
christmas it's really remarkable
100 million shots in arms by the end of
february is very much in scope
meanwhile president trump says white
house officials will not be given
vaccination priority
despite claims from the nsc the
president tweeting
if people working in the white house
should receive the vaccine somewhat
later in the program unless
specifically necessary also keep in mind
those front line workers as well as
nursing home residents
will be the first two in line to get
these vaccinations today back to you
guys
thank you so much ashley